Ném mừng xin tháng 2 năm, ngày 29, tông tin từ công an thành phố Đàn Nắng,
đơn vị vừa trị sóa thành công an điểm 1 bản thiết bị,
phóng tệ phục vụ hành vi giá lận trong hạt động tổ chức đánh bạc,
đánh bạc trên địa bản thành phố.
Các địa này, sau để tế hát, sinh 1,5 xin xam sống mít tư,
chú phần an kê, và nâng 1 á, sinh 1,5 xin xam xin mít tư, chú phần hó khánh,
chức tiếp tổ chức hạt động.
Tại điểm đường vấn quyền, phần an kê, khắp hiện tạm giữ,
tâm trong bộ bài tây có má vệ cùng các tăng bật khác như,
mù lấy trái đánh tý vị địa từ bảo dân,
để thoại thông minh cài đặt phần mềm xe mạnh,
để thoại phí bấm dùng về xin camera soi xúc sắp,
ảo đã gắn tý vị dùng, còn tay cảm nhận dùng,
kinh áp trong nhìn bài tây có má vệ tổng giá chiếm mua và ước tính khoảng
tảm bí hai chựa đồng, dự kiến phán xà với giá hơn 1 chăm múng mấy chựa đồng.
Tại điểm đường hoàn bân thái phường hò khánh, phát hiện tạm giữ,
5 bộ bài tây đã qua sự dùng có giống hiệu làm giấu xanh lệ,
các tăng bật khác như,
ảo khoảng dùng về giấu bài,
mù lấy trái đánh tý vị bảo dân,
điều khiến xèo tổ dùng để gắn tý vị xanh lệ,
tổng giá chiếm mua và khoảng 20 chựa đồng,
bán xà khoảng 30 chựa đồng.
Cơ lời thực hành đámu có tý vị từ mạng xóh hội,
xanh thương mạng giữ,
sau đó bán lại cho các lời tự trên địa bàn thành phố đàn bán vầy yếu tình,
thành khác trên cẩn nước.
Hình không cạnh rất hiện sự đã bàn xáu tổng bộ hồ sơ,
tăng bật liên quan trở công hàn phường ăn khi và công hàn phường hòa khánh tiếp tục tủ lý,
dạc biết thật thần quyền.